all people are sitting around the table  talking about baseball whatever you like  five minutes of it very dull  suddenly  a bomb goes up  blows the people to smith  what do the audience have  10 seconds of shock  now take the same scene  and tell the audience there is a bomb  under that table  and will go off in five minutes  well the whole emotion of the audience  is totally different because you've  given them that information  now the conversation about baseball  becomes very vital  because they're saying to you don't be  ridiculous stop talking about baseball  there's a bomb under them  you've got the audience working  [Music]